this non-binding resolution was based on
a fundamental principle of the UN
Charter it is against international law
for one member state to invade another
Ukraine and the EU wanted as many member
states as possible to vote in favor of
their draft and knew from recent history
that anything more strongly worded would
lose support and the strategy paid off
with 141 of the 193 members of the UN
General Assembly voting in favor seven
voting against and 32 abstaining the
message is clear
it doesn't matter
what Russia tries and how it attempts to
undermine International order
and the coalition
in support of Ukraine's territorial
Integrity it fails these 141 countries
reiterated a clear demand to Russia
withdraw
withdraw immediately completely and
unconditionally from Ukraine's
internationally recognized territory as
expected several key non-aligned
countries abstained including China
South Africa and India they argued that
a resolution that sought to contribute
to a lasting peace in the region should
focus on achieving a ceasefire immediate
peace talks and addressing the
geopolitical concerns that led to the
conflict in the first place
boosting or even enlarging military
blocks will only undermine Regional
security and drive peace further away
the final settlement of the Ukraine
crisis hinges on abandoning the Cold War
mentality and giving direction to and
respecting the reasonable security
concerns of all countries while we take
note of the stated objectives of today's
resolution given its inherent
limitations in reaching our desired goal
of securing lasting peace
we are constrained to abstain
and even though several non-aligned
countries like Nigeria and Indonesia did
vote for the resolution they registered
their reservations criticizing it for
not promoting peace talks and conflict
resolution Ukraine the EU and the U.S
can once again say that a majority of
Nations at the U.N General Assembly has
voted against the Russian invasion even
of finding Unity on more punitive
actions against Moscow has proved more
elusive
Al Jazeera the United Nations